can I build a set of movie accurate
stormtrooper armor in under a month
let's find out when you get a kit to
build stormtrooper armor it comes out of
the box looking like this and I'm
supposed to turn it into this wish me
luck with only 30 days to finish the
armor I got straight to work building
stormtrooper armor involves three main
steps trimming sanding and gluing 2
weeks in I had only completed the arms
and the legs and it was looking like I
might not get it done in time after
several setbacks though I finally got a
Dremel and it sent me into hyperspace I
was able to get the rest of the parts
done way faster and with almost no time
to spare it was finally finished this
armor looks incredible I love how it
turned out and I'm proud to say I'm a
real Stormtrooper now it's crazy to
believe that this all started with a
simple question though